loads of things on the market uh you
know expensive devices to check lying
you know big lie detectors polygraph
tests and all that sort of stuff they
cost thousands well licensed fee pairs
relax
we found one uh over the internet just
got a few quid right and uh it's in here
this is it now uh how do i turn that on
do i hit that yes i do and basically you
see there
it's a big apple
and that means it's true and then if
you're not telling the truth the apple
oh
now
what that means i'm lying
is that the actual one they use with the
fbi
[Applause]
graham cause you go toilet
find out if he really wants to go to the
toilet yeah oh that's a good idea
if you don't hurry up i'll go here
[Music]
[Applause]
okay i remind you olivia and john
at least he's got a toilet
you'll be fine olivia listen quickly we
can try it we do we could do a totally
honest
uh version of our show totally honestly
so
welcome to the show my guest is ricky
gervais
yes that is true yes
thank you
you look very handsome
we didn't lose the whole apple soda
a few bites big bites
so do you
we lost the whole apple
[Applause]
is this the only show you're doing to
talk about your film
no
i'm doing every piece of to tell
you there is going
[Applause]
so bad i'm actually wishing
you were alan titchmarsh
i wish you were zac efron
[Applause]
[Music]
you